-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out
with Chris Evans right now.
"Ghosted" is his movie.
And we're about to play
the "Whisper Challenge."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whisper challenge.
-Now, here's how the game works.
You can play this at home
if you'd like.
One person puts
on these headphones
with loud music playing, okay?
Then the other person
picks up a card.
I have these cards here.
Okay.
And you're going to read
the random phrase on that card.
The person wearing
the headphones has to try
to guess what they just said
just by reading your lips.
Alright? Chris, go ahead
and put on the headphones.
-I put on the --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think we're gonna be good.
Alright,
I'll play the music now.
Hold on.
That should be kind of on.
Is that -- Ooh, ooh.
It's a bop. It's a bop.
Come on, it's a Chris Evans bop.
-Wait, wait, wait.
-Oh, sorry.
Oh, now it's good.
Oh, yeah.
I can now hear it
through your headphones.
Alright, good.
Alright, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-This is so funny.
-Boo!
-Poo?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Boo.
-Poo.
[ Laughter ]
-Boo!
-Yes! Very good. Yes.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's harder than you think.
Alright, Come on.
Alright, we got that one.
We got that one.
Come on. Oh, wow!
-Okay.
Yeah, I went for it.
Alright, ready?
This is really fun.
Oh, I love it.
[ Laughter ]
Dunkin Coolatta.
-Talking to Idalia.
-You didn't even let me finish.
Wait, wait.
-Yep.
Dunkin Coolatta.
-Talking Ilana.
[ Laughter ]
-Dunkin.
-Talking.
-Coolatta.
-Quilata?
-Close. Close.
-Oh, Coolatta?
Dunkin Coolatta?
-Bam!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know about Dunkin Coolatta!
Dude, Dunkin Coolatta is my jam!
Come on!
Dunkin Coolatta.
It looks like "talking."
Talking.
-I could play this game
for hours.
-Yeah, let's do it. Let's do it.
Let's do it. Alright, bud.
Let me know if it's working.
Yeah. Okay.
Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
Weed whacker.
-Weed whacker.
-Yes! Wait, what?
[ Dinging ]
-That was too easy.
That was too easy.
-How?
-I didn't even --
Yeah, that was too easy.
-How did you get weed whacker?
-That was too easy.
-It was?
-It looked like weed whacker.
-Alright, good. Alright.
That's what I'm
talking about, dude.
That's a good partner
right there.
This is for all the marbles.
Let's do it.
-Okay. Okay. I like it.
[ Laughter ]
Duck, duck, goose.
-That was it? Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, sorry. Ready? And...
-Duck, duck, goose.
-Sorry again. One more time.
-Tell the truth.
[ Laughter ]
Duck, duck, goose.
-Touch the --
[ Laughter ]
Touch the juice?
[ Rimshot ]
-Duck, duck, goose.
[ Laughter ]
-Tattoo juice.
-Duck, duck, goose.
-Is that another name for beer?
Tattoo juice.
-Duck, duck, goose.
-Talk, talk --
-Duck, duck, goose!
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Chris Evans, everybody.
His movie "Ghosted" premieres
on Apple TV+ this Friday.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break. Stick around.
Duck, duck, goose.